the battle for New Hampshire begins
after Donald Trump dominates in Iowa 31
minutes is all the time it took for the
former president to be declared the
winner of the Iowa caucuses Trump
breaking several records and carrying 98
out of the state's 99 counties in a
landslide Victory the former president
says it's time for the party to unite
and take on President Biden so I don't
want to be overly uh rough on the
president but I have to say that he is
the worst president that we've had in
the history of our country and I really
think this is time now for everybody our
country to come together I want to
congratulate Ron and Nikki for having a
a good a good time together we're all
having a good time together but the
runners up aren't finished yet bronda
santz and Nikki Haley brushing off their
losses and trying to argue that the race
isn't
over because of your support in spite of
all of that that they threw at us
everyone against us we've got our ticket
punched out of Iowa I can safely say
tonight Iowa made this Republican
primary a twers
race but not everybody's going to New
Hampshire F ramas Swami dropping out and
endorsing Trump we are going to suspend
this presidential
campaign and this is is going to have to
be there is no path for me to be the
next president as I've said since the
beginning there are two America First
candidates in this race and earlier
tonight I called Donald Trump to tell
him that I congratulated him on his
victory and now going forward he will
have my full endorsement for the
presidency all right judge J pero you
watched all last night even stayed up
till midnight to see Harold Ford Jr
yes I did you know I don't see enough of
them here okay uh first of all I thought
it was huge everybody knows it was
historic 98 out of 99 counties and the
99th County lost by one vote but look it
it was a landslide and so the question
is what happens now I mean is this it
now I really think it's amazing that
Nikki Haley comes out she's third and
she says it's now a two-party race and
I'm only going to debate Donald Trump or
Biden news for Nikki Biden ain't uh
debating anybody that's number one and
number two with Ronda Sans is talking
about how great it was the truth is he
doesn't have a path forward because he's
not that he's not skipping New Hampshire
but he's going right to South Carolina
he's not spending a lot of time in New
Hampshire and it makes sense because the
truth is in New Hampshire he's at about
6% so here's the question at the next
stage in New Hampshire if Nikki haly is
at 29 and she gets Chris Christie's
votes that brings her to 40% Trump's at
43 he gets ramas Swami's vote that
brings him to
50% and the santis is at 6.5 so Trump
wins but you know what for people who
don't think who think it's too early to
call the truth is that Donald Trump got
more votes than the three of them
combined Nikki and Ras Swami and uh
santis and the truth is people in Iowa
support his agenda they felt that he's
the kind of guy who works for them and
fights for people like them and the
amazing thing too is that he got a
bigger percentage of college graduates
than they did he got a bigger percentage
of suburban Urban he got across the
board and the people in Iowa that is not
exactly a border state are like
immigration is the biggest issue so this
is is a resounding win for Trump not
just for what happened in Iowa but as
you look forward you say to yourself
those other guys don't have a chance
let's look forward I mean how long will
it take for people to just kind of
realize what's going on Harold for Jr
good to be back around this table on the
table Iowa last night say a couple
things I think the Judge is right you
can't underestimate uh this Victory last
night for for former president Trump two
things one he had an organization on the
ground unlike he had seven eight years
ago
uh when he he didn't win in Iowa this
year he had an organization uh they
campaigned uh he didn't spend as much
time as the other two candidates uh but
he had some benefits and advantages they
did not have uh two his speech after
winning I thought was remarkable for him
uh it demonstrated I think judge your
instinct which and I others in the party
Republican part who far be it from me to
try to give advice to Republicans but
it's someone who loves the serious
business of politics and watching
politicians uh try to perform and
perform at their best I thought him uh
talking in a cordial collegial and
consolatory way to uh his opponents
particularly after he had won a majority
of the vote I thought was a clear sign
that he understands what it means to be
a presidential candidate and what it's
going to mean to bring the party
together and perhaps even bring
Independence his way three U the santis
and and and Haley I was surprised the
santis had no magnanimous nature to his
speech he basically acted as if he had
won last night and gave us a history
lesson uh and uh from the Revolutionary
War to the Civil War which I found
interesting because I like those kinds
of things but I don't know what
necessarily had to do with last night I
thought he should have been more
magnanimous and Cong he never
congratulated president Trump nor he
congratulated U Miss Haley nor did he
thank a volunteer uh Trump went on to
thank every volunteer in fact he brought
a guy on stage who was dressed as a wall
uh in the front row to say thank you to
him and I think there was another state
senator who had supported him very early
the campaign I think the only thing if
you were if you're in the Haley campaign
or the sanos campaign you may say you
may not like me saying this but I think
if you were in that campaign you say
look do one of you two of you need to
stay around at least another week or two
for two reasons one if you're Haley are
you a candidate to be VP and if you win
New Hampshire do you make a stronger
case for yourself and then two if
something by some strange chance happens
to president Trump and he can't be the
nominee for whatever reason do you hang
around a little bit but I think if you
just suspend your campaign I think you
give you leave open the opportunity uh
to be able to unsuspended uh to be able
to get back in the race but without
question this was a tremendous night for
former president Trump well the Andra
suspended and he's going to be joining
Donald Trump at a rally this evening in
New Hampshire also will be on Jesse
waters's Prime Time what kind of impact
do you think vake and his endorsement
will have I think that's obviously he's
throwing his support to Donald Trump um
and he already had a very strong night
he's expeced to have another strong
showing in New Hampshire I think you
have to look at those voters in Iowa
that said that they are looking for
substantial change 89% want at least
substantial change in how this country
is run I mean V ran on that obviously he
was reaching out to those voters didn't
quite reach enough of them um but they
don't like the way the country is going
the direction it is in they don't like
their finances but don't underestimate
and I think we could this a big takeaway
from last night the impact that the
immigration border chaos is having on
the mind of the American voter right now
they don't like what they see happening
in their cities in their towns they
don't like the lawlessness that they're
seeing at the border for that to rate
above the economy and the most pressing
issues facing the country today that is
pretty remarkable I mean you can start
to lump those two together right the
immigration um chaos and the economy
people see the economic impact that's
having on their neighborhoods their
towns uh their businesses um all of it
sort of coming together I mean there
were so many remarkable data points in
favor of Donald Trump I mean when you
even look at foreign policy which was
number three on the list of concerns
facing the country for the voter on the
ground in Iowa's foreign policy Nikki
Haley should have ran away with that
Donald Trump swept that as well I mean
Nicki Haley came in a close second but
he was winning every single one of these
categories um so he had an incredibly
strong showing and even in the urban and
Suburban communities we know he's strong
in the rural areas but he won the
largest share of Voters who said they
lived in the urban and Suburban
communities um so he reached just about
everybody all those I um those Iowa
voters who are looking for Change and
change in leadership and you know you
got to you got to give him credit to
santis he was on the ground he tried to
reach those voters Harold I think to
your point when we were all listening to
that speech he was so happy to be number
two
yes well you know what that means I mean
he's the first to lose so I mean but
still you'd be magnanimous you thank
your you thank people right that's my
only point I thought he should have with
that I do all right
GG well you know uh you know when do you
ever think about you know when somebody
might ask you to go see the Titanic you
know but you know how it's going to end
but you go you sit down you pretend you
don't know how it's going to end and you
act like you're really surprised I feel
like that's what this is we knew how
this was going to end we knew that it
was going to be a blowout you know but
we still had to pretend that there was
this anxious anticipation and then we
have the us and what happens we call it
in 30 minutes that's like going to see
the Titanic okay I'll sit down I'm
committed to this and then the movie
breaks in 30 minutes because you already
know the ending yeah you already know
the ending so why watch the rest of it
well if that's the case let's call the
whole thing early if you're right and I
believe you are there's no path forward
for these other candidates so why don't
the Republicans do what the Dems are
doing and play for the general election
right you know just because Trump blew
everybody out in Iowa doesn't mean
that's going to happen November you have
to start thinking about that the Dems
are pulling out every weapon to stop
orange Hitler and I want to make sure
that the other side is also doing the
same regarding Joe's atrocious record
and I kind sometimes wonder that all of
this money that is being spent $300
million uh you know like for what for
for uh a frozen night in Iowa that we
knew was going to end this way and we're
all so surprised but we spent 300
million on candidate karaoke When in
fact you know you should actually be
focusing on the big picture like how are
you going to do this after four years of
hitleri where you know they they
basically demeaned half the population
this is why VI is important because he
could be a tremendous asset for Trump
because Trump may not have the patience
to
articulate why people with TDS should
listen right he's you know V is like a
he has Ben Shapiro's brain Victor Davis
Hansen's wisdom and my looks and you saw
how he you saw how V handles reporters
and protesters he's him with Trump could
be like Starsky and Hutch or Crockett or
tubs or lever and Shirley sit in Nancy
I'm running out but if you turn VI loose
on TDS he would be the best spokesman
for the message to people that are still
uncomfortable with Trump you know the
beliefs are the same make America great
that meritocracy is necessary America
First focus on citizens and not Foreign
Wars The Border Law and Order I think
that's the that's the message what about
San Fran's son I
think how could you forget I was
thinking V press secretary now I think
right now he needs he needs somebody out
there to to because like you're going to
have you're going to have to melt a lot
of this TDS okay well I think VI can do
it and then we'll make him a press
secretary yeah it's already happening he
doesn't even know it yet hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now